In this lecture,
we continue our discussion of the manifestation of mutual assent by considering
Lucy versus Zimmer in 1954 Virginia Case in which the promise or appeared to
assent to a contract,
but later claimed this,
a offer that his offer was merely a joke in Lucy versus Zimmer.
The defendant Zimmer drafted and executed a short written agreement on the back
of a restaurant receipt to sell his farm for $50,000 to the plaintiff.
Lucy Zimmer subsequently refused to consummate the sale asserting that he didn't
ever believe Lucy had $50,000 and that the offer that he had made was just
ingest.
Lucy sought specific enforcement of the sale agreement the trial court found for
Zimmer,
but the instinct court reversed.
So what's the central issue?
Did Zimmers action bind him contractually,
despite his claimed subjective intent to joke,
the court held that it did concluding that the agreement constituted a binding
contract of sale between the two parties,
whether it was quote,
the result of a serious offered by Lucy and a serious acceptance by the
defendants,
or was a serious offer by Lucy and an acceptance in secret.
Just by the defendants
to reach this conclusion.
The court cited the rule that the law imputes to a person and intention
corresponding to the reasonable meaning of his words and acts.
This is another example of the objective listener standard.
In other words,
the court applied the objective theory of manifestation of mutual assent that we
discussed in the last lecture,
the uninsured undisclosed intention of the promise or is immaterial if his
outward actions would lead a reasonable person to conclude that he intends to
form a contract.
This case is arguably the poster child for a very formalist version of the
objective theory.
At a minimum,
the case stands for the rule that court should look at a parties outward
expression rather than the internal intention of the party.
In this case,
there's actually the outward manifestation of two parties,
uh,
on the two sellers in the sense that both both Zimmer's,
both of the spouses,
uh,
manifested a intent to contract,
and that even if one of those sellers was jesting,
I think it's important that the other spouse also signed,
helps to add to the court's willingness to enforce the contract.
And now and an opinion by one of America's most famous and aptly named judges.
Judge learned hand provides with an extreme statement of the objective theory of
agreement.
Hand said a contract has strictly speaking nothing to do with the personal or
individual intent of the parties.
A contract is an obligation attached by mere force of law to certain acts of the
parties,
usually words which ordinarily company and represent a known intent.
If however,
it were approved by 20 bishops that either party when he used those words
intended something else than the usual meaning which the law imposes upon them,
he would still be held unless there were some mutual mistake or something else
of that sort.
So why should this be the rule?
Even if some people attach idiosyncratic meaning to their words or actions,
it may be more efficient to make those people change rather to then to make the
majority change.
The idiosyncratic bargainers could probably adjust their behavior more easily
and at a lower cost than the majority.
Part of the efficiency from the objective listener standard is that it allows
contract law to avoid jury questions and have disputes decided instead on the
papers.
Under a subjective theory,
a defendant might cause almost any case to go to trial to decide whether both
parties really intended to contract.
One way to justify Zimmers liability in this case is to focus on how
inconsiderate the Zimmer's defense is with regard to other contract writers.
If Zimmer wins,
written contracts become less useful.
A completely subjective theory of intent also creates a serious moral hazard
problem.
Parties who later wished to get out or modify regrettable bargains could claim
idiosyncratic meanings after the fact,
as frank Easterbrook puts it.
If unilateral or secret intentions could bind,
parties would become wary and the written word would lose some of its power.
This is a case where the future written contract sellers are likely rooting
against Zimmer.
So after signing the agreement,
imagine that Zimmer immediately tells Lucy that it was all a joke and he doesn't
intend to sell his farm.
Under this objective theory is the contract binding.
The answer's yes and offer or may revoke an offer.
Until it is accepted,
but not after it's accepted.
If Zimmer is outward,
actions imply that the offer is serious.
A contract is formed as soon as Lucy accepts it under the objective theory,
and if it is too late for Zimmer to revoke by revealing that he has secretly
joking,
uh,
then he can't retract the contract.
In fact,
in Lucy versus Zimmer,
Zimmer argued that he did tell Lucy that the whole thing was a joke immediately
after the contract was signed and he realized that Lucy was serious,
but that wasn't enough to avoid Zimmers liability.
But is this really a good rule?
Malcolm sharp who emphasizes the freedom from contract argues that in light of
the cost,
individual freedom,
the objective tests should be employed to only where the defendant has induced
actual unjustified reliance by the plaintiff.
If Zimmer told Lucy that he was joking before Lucy left the bar,
then what difference does it make to Lucy?
Lucy hasn't yet relied on the promise,
so is no worse off than he would have been had.
Zimmer told him it was a joke immediately before assigning or and refusing to
sign.
Sharps reliance approach is not perfect.
However,
uh,
whether the promise he relied on the promise can itself be a matter of dispute
that may require jury adjudication of whether there was actual and justified
reliance.
There would be fewer summary Judgments and directed verdicts if there was a
required a reliance requirement.
So let's recap for two parties to establish a valid contract.
There must be a manifestation of mutual assent by both parties.
Under the objective theory,
whether a scent is manifested is determined by the actions of the parties.
And so a party may be bound despite a hidden contrary intent,
the reasonable listener standard determines whether someone has manifested a
scent.